I like peanut butter Daniel Dwyer likes
peanut butter and Winston likes peanut
butter it's time to talk about the ape
scientist himself Winston what is this
guy all about an overwatch yeah
Winston's a weird one because you kind
of think Winston's one character but is
actually a totally different character
he's not your sort of big bruising you
know massive damage tank tick and
running and like take on a massive bunch
of people but he's definitely capable of
jumping into groups of people are taking
out individuals and then kind of like
free very quickly he's he's kind of a
disrupting character I'd say and key to
that disruption is his mobility which he
has a jump pack and that allows him to
leap any direction you're looking you
can get high elevation points you can
cover a lot of lateral distance and that
allows you to get into a place that the
team is your enemies are not expecting
you to be and start mixing it up for
sure I there's a tendency to sort of
jump from the outside into the middle of
a battle when you first start using
Winston and the cooldown on it is a
little bit longer than you might want in
some situations especially for in a
fight so it's often best used to get out
of situations so you can go in there
dump a load of a damage using your Tesla
Connor on an individual or on a group
and then sort of jumping out of there
from there or if you see somebody who's
like fleeing for instance it's great at
closing the distance if you see a an
assault or a defense character who
you're definitely gonna be able to take
out using either you're gone or your
melee which is actually pretty strong
Winston takes off 50 damage and you can
start up the jump ice light one of them
and then murder them and try and get out
as quickly as possible and another tool
to keep in mind when you're doing this
jumping in is your barrier projector it
creates a spherical shield around
Winston wherever he is and it's gonna
block incoming damage which allows you
not to trap anyone in there because
people can walk back and forth through
this barrier freely but to focus down on
one character who may be in the bubble
with you while they're people outside
the bubble can't really support them by
shooting you because the barrier is
taking that damage exactly I mean when
you first use it it looks like something
that would be perfect for the payload
like Rinehart shield it kind of
disappears pretty quickly and is easy to
destroy so yeah it's best to use I think
to jump into packs of people and to sort
of isolate them from the pack if four
people are shooting at you but you pop
the bubble and one of them's in the
bubble they still think that is through
other people shooting you along with
them when really they're stuck inside of
a bubble
of eight so that's a really good
effective use of the barrier projector
so you can jump in do some damage pop
the barrier to keep that damage off you
and then hopefully your jump out will be
charged by then but let's look a little
bit about the Tesla cannon itself
because this is a weapon that you don't
have to aim at just one person it chains
to nearby people and also in terms of
aiming you don't really have to keep the
reticle on so you are free to jump
around a lot and that disrupt people
trying to get a clean shot on you yeah
for sure it damages multiple people
which is very handy means you don't have
to you know if you're not comfortable as
a FPS person for instance this is
actually a really good tool to use right
off the bat at the Tesla cannon also
able to get through Reinhardt shield for
instance also Winston's bubble as well
an enemy Winston and so there's sort of
uses there it's also impossible for
Genji to block this so if you're playing
again gee he tries to use his deflect to
stop you it does actually work so he'll
be there flailing a sword around while
you're just like dumping Tessa just
zapped in the crap out of this dude yeah
it's it's a handy thing it takes off a
lot of damage the only problem with it
is you need to be very very close and
this is Winston's sort of biggest
problem is that he doesn't have any
range whatsoever really even with
results you really need to be on top of
people so with the test I can adjust be
aware of that you need to be pretty
close to people and then you know if a
lot of people are talking you get it
editor quick and live to fight another
day it's also great for sweeping an area
clean of symmetric turrets now let's
talk Altima primal rage he freaks out he
gains a ton of health and you can just
kind of jump around infinitely and punch
people yeah there's a tendency with
primal rage to then use it to jump in
and try and kill everyone and you should
jump in and destroy people because
you're basically you've got this massive
amount of health and a large amount of
damage and you're able to jump as much
as you can but don't really focus on
trying to kill individual people because
you're just gonna punch them chase after
them and try and punch them again use it
more to destruct people so if you're on
say an attacking team trying to burst
through an area of the map this is a
perfect example of a situation where you
should pop that old get in there destroy
people knock them at it away and try and
get your team through there and if
you're got an oncoming team coming
towards you and they're all packing
together around a payload for instance
again pop that off jump in there and
just knock people all over the place
disrupt them make them sort of upset in
that way and if you can knock them back
towards your team all better they'll be
even closer for your teammates
eat them up exactly in fact it's
something with farmer rage especially
with new players that if you pop that
alts they just run like they're scared
of this massive a running around who
wouldn't be and it doesn't happen so
much in sort of higher level play
because people are kind of know
Winston's limitations but especially
when you're first sort of playing over
watch this it's a really powerful sort
of mental game so there you have it play
Winston as a mobile tank get in do
damage get out disrupt the other team
and hey when you're attacking a point
the area coverage of that Tesla cannon
is great for locking down close spaces
that's Winston for you folks here on our
overwatch hero guide stay tuned to game
spot give us a subscribe and we'll be
having more for you shortly